[Música]
una de las preguntas que me hacen con
mayor frecuencia es cómo le hago para
ser famosa es sociales de hecho hay
jóvenes entre 12 y 18 años que al
preguntarles qué quieren ser de grandes
te responden youtuber y no tiene
absolutamente nada de malo los medios
digitales de hecho están revolucionando
los modelos de negocio de publicidad y
de hecho también yo me dedico a eso aquí
la diferencia radica en por qué quieres
ser famoso
todos asociamos la fama con tener una
vida perfecta llena de lujos de
oportunidades y de ventajas
ustedes conocían los famosos sismógrafos
los que son muy jóvenes tal vez no les
tocaron estas maravillas eran unas
libretas tamaño carta que circulaban
alrededor de los salones con los chismes
más candentes del momento a karen le
gusta pedrito fulanito está estrenando
casa
en ese momento estas libretas se
llamaban sismógrafos hoy como creen que
se llaman
redes sociales exactamente en las redes
sociales vemos contenido como hay no
hacer le pidieron matrimonio se ve que
son la pareja ideal me muero los amo
y en otra vemos maría se fue a la playa
con sus amigas me encantaría tener su
dinero
me encantaría tener su cuerpo
y con esta información nos hacemos creer
a nosotros mismos que las vidas
perfectas si existen y alimentamos a
nuestra mente haciéndole creer que los
cuerpos perfectos existen que las vidas
perfectas existen las familias y los
trabajos perfectos existen
yo me acuerdo muy bien que vi una vez
una pareja en instagram que para mí eran
la perfección en el amor besos risas
viajes y ese agua o son perfectos unos
meses después tuve la oportunidad de
conocerlos en persona y me di cuenta que
era todo lo contrario y no era porque se
obviarán y se pelearan simplemente eran
personas normales parejas normales con
diferencias como ustedes y como yo
vamos a hacer un ejercicio corto quiero
que sean sinceros estamos en confianza
cuántos de ustedes han borrado alguna
publicación en redes sociales porque no
tienen suficientes likes
digan la verdad están mintiendo sí muy
bien exacto
nos gusta mucho esta sensación de
aprobación de gustarle a los demás
pareciera ser adictiva no y muchos
ustedes que no levantaron la mano están
pensando no la verdad a mí me da igual
las redes sociales ni me importa yo ni
instagram tengo y qué bueno sin embargo
algo que nos debería de preocupar a
todos es que la tasa de suicidios en
jóvenes está aumentando gracias a las
redes sociales porque nosotros mismos
nos creemos está idea de que las vías
perfectas existen y que aparentemente
todos la tienen
- tú
todos tuvimos nuestros momentos
perfectos porque porque es lo que
queremos que trascienda es lo que
queremos recordar en un futuro cuántos
de ustedes se suben llorando en su
cuarto porque su proyecto en el que
tanto trabajaron fracaso o porque les
está yendo mal económicamente o porque
cortaron porque se divorciaron nosotros
no subimos este tipo de contenido porque
no queremos que trascienda todos
vendemos vidas perfectas en redes
sociales y es un tanto normal pero como
dice andy stalman en su libro you man of
on todos tenemos una vida online y una
vida offline la vida online es esta vida
perfecta que nos gusta recordar la vida
offline es un conjunto de circunstancias
que pasan día con día a ustedes a mí y a
la persona más famosa del mundo
tengo 5 años siendo blogger trabajando
con marcas nacionales e internacionales
y dos años con la agencia creativa de
mis más grandes sueños en uno de estos
viajes yo estaba logrando algo increíble
para mí me sentía feliz me sentía soñada
me sentía realizada en uno de esos
momentos y unas pausas me metí a
instagram como cualquier otro día me
topé con una conocida que había logrado
algo aparentemente más grande y más
importante que lo mío
en ese momento me abordó un sentimiento
un tanto nuevo y extraño una angustia de
sentir que lo que yo había hecho no era
suficiente que lo que la persona detrás
de mi pantalla estaba logrando era más
importante que lo mío afortunadamente
soy una persona consciente e
inmediatamente detecte ese extraño
sentimiento y durante semanas y semanas
estuve dando vueltas a este tema y
llegué a la conclusión de preguntarme
qué es para ti el éxito la fama es
temporal la fama la puede crear alguien
que haga un chisme incluso un
delincuente puede hacer puede ser famoso
una persona muy guapa puede ser famosa o
alguien con mucho talento pero aquí la
diferencia radica en que es lo que le
estás dejando a las personas como las
estás haciendo sentir que estaba siendo
exitosa y sin embargo los mismos
parámetros que yo solita me puse me
estaban diciendo que no era lo
suficiente y entonces dije pues como
entonces cada que logré algo no va a
sentir mal porque si así a eso nos vamos
y me pongo a compararme con cada extraño
en un dispositivo móvil va a parecer que
nunca va a ser suficiente porque siempre
habrá alguien que lo haga mejor que yo o
que haga lo mismo pero en dubai
porque no dejar de compararme porque no
dejar de hacer mis logros más chicos
porque no disfrutar la persona que soy
hoy con lo que tengo y con lo que soy
porque esforzarme tanto en gustarle a
los demás y mejor esforzarme en gustarme
a mí misma
para mí el éxito descubrí que es la
capacidad de cumplir con tu propósito de
vida de disfrutar la persona en la que
te conviertes día con día y dejar tu
granito de arena en al menos una persona
y ahí fue entendí ahí fue que entendí
que para mí la única competencia era yo
misma y no una persona detrás de una
pantalla y fue que decidí
que para mí era más importante ser
exitosa que famosa
hoy a mis 26 años he logrado cosas que
sinceramente no hubiera logrado si no
hubiera sido por una herramienta tan
increíble que cambió por completo a mi
vida fueron las mismas redes sociales
las redes sociales son increíbles
tenemos el mundo en nuestras manos pero
todo depende en como las utilicemos
pero encontré mi propósito de vida y mi
manera de impactar al mundo y a las
personas que me sigan es con el ejemplo
porque como bien dice la frase las cosas
no se dicen se hacen porque al hacerlas
se dicen solas
una de las áreas creativas de mi estudio
se dedica a impulsar marcas y proyectos
personales en medios digitales y no
saben cómo lo disfruto es impresionante
el alcance que podemos tener con una
buena estrategia de redes sociales pero
yo le pregunto a mis clientes qué es lo
que quieres dejarle a las personas que
estás aportando le a la gente 'creemos
este mundo digital un mundo más
agradable un mundo de aprendizaje de
inspiración de conexión y todo eso
depende de todos nosotros porque debemos
entender que somos responsables al crear
contenido y al consumirlo
todos absolutamente todos somos un
conjunto de las personas con las que más
convivimos con los libros que leemos los
viajes que hacemos lo que tenemos
alrededor es lo que somos ahora al lado
de este dato pongan la estadística que
los jóvenes entre 12 y 24 años pasan un
promedio de 4 horas diarias en un
dispositivo móvil
en una edad en la que estás creando la
persona que quiere ser en dónde estás
forjando tus sueños y en que te a quién
te quieres convertir básicamente las
redes sociales están educando a los
jóvenes que van a ser el futuro de
nuestro país y el mundo en general
muchos jóvenes se burlan de medios
antiguos como la televisión sin darse
cuenta que ese mismo contenido solo pasó
a otra red social pero es el mismo por
ejemplo antes si tú querías
conseguir un novio o una novia pues si
vas a una fiesta te lo presentaba un
amigo ibas a la universidad hoy en día
con el celular puedes literalmente
escoger entre miles de personas a tu
pareja ideal
hoy en día si el über no llega en cinco
minutos ya le cancela aste ya te
desesperas te ya le estás marcando los
medios digitales nos han acostumbrado a
creer todo rápido fácil y sencillo
cuando es todo lo contrario yo
personalmente antes de este proyecto que
hace que hoy esté parada aquí intenté
abrir tres blogs y todos fracasaron por
esa misma razón porque yo ya estaba
acostumbrada a que todo rápido fácil y
sencillo
entonces qué es lo que cambio entre ese
proyecto y los otros
en la intención
en dejar de preocuparme por el número de
likes por el número de seguidores por
las personas que les gustará mi
contenido no si las marcas me marcaban o
no y fue sólo así eliminando este
concepto que yo sola me puse de fama y
de competencia fue que logré reconectar
conmigo misma y disfrutar de lo que
hacía por él simplemente hecho de darme
el gusto y de hacer lo que a mí me gusta
tú no eres el número de likes que tienen
tus fotos tú no eres el número de
seguidores que tiene tu proyecto tú eres
lo que te mueve tú eres lo que te
inspira tú eres lo que dejas en las
personas a veces queremos darle gusto a
todo el mundo y nos olvidamos de darle
gusto a la persona más importante que
eres tú
los medios digitales son una herramienta
increíble tenemos el mundo en nuestras
manos pero solo si sabemos utilizarlas
han escuchado la frase de tú eres lo que
comes pues en este caso tú eres lo que
consumes en redes sociales o mejor dicho
dime a quién sigues y te diré quién eres
gracias